we did this long-form piece in November
of 2017 debunking a lot of the myths
surrounding race and intelligence and IQ
and we did it right after this topic
sort of exploded with sam harris and
charles murray and ezra klein and at the
time there was just a ton of discussion
on youtube and elsewhere about race and
IQ and i thought it was necessary at the
time to deconstruct some of the
so-called scientific racism narratives
which have actually always been around
but were really popularized right around
that time about a year and a half ago or
so and i wasn't gonna do any more on the
subject i think we said what we needed
to say it's not something that we talk
about often on the program very much
anymore but i decided to do a sort of
one time follow-up to that video based
on the feedback that I've gotten since
then the video that we originally did
got more than a quarter million views it
has about 30% dislikes which is not
super surprising it still gets views and
I'm continuing to hear from people about
it and I want to address a couple of the
different types of criticisms that I get
about the video people have said things
like if it's okay to say that certain
races are better at sports why is it
wrong to make the same sort of
observations about race and intelligence
now this kind of argument isn't always
worded in this exact same way but it's a
common one that you hear and I think
that this athletics and intelligence
analogy could maybe be a good
jumping-off point to explore racial
taboos and what a lot of people just
aren't understanding about this so to
begin with if we're just talking about
taboos many people do find it offensive
when certain races are stereotyped as
being better at sports racial
stereotypes tend to be offensive to a
lot of people whether they're positive
or negative stereotypes but going beyond
that stereotypes about athletic ability
and stereotypes about intellectual
ability have very different implications
and people who equate the two are just
pretending that they don't know that or
genuinely don't know it most employers
don't care about the natural athletic
abilities of a job applicant being
stereotyped as someone who's probably
at sports or certain sports is not going
to significantly impact you in most of
the real world with some exceptions
being stereotyped as someone who's
probably smart very well may help you in
life so being equated equating athletics
with intelligence in order to argue that
race and IQ shouldn't be taboo or
shouldn't be handled with sensitivity is
probably just pretending not to
understand that there's a real
significant difference between the two
when someone says we can talk about race
and athletic ability so we should be
allowed to talk about race and
intelligence this person might also be
ignoring the social causes behind why
certain races are more successful in
certain sports the same way that people
ignore the social aspects of IQ certain
sports are way more ingrained in certain
cultures so for example despite Latin
Americans disproportionate
representation in baseball would be
pretty ridiculous to say that they are
genetically predisposed to excel at
baseball or to say that Northern
Europeans have a genetic inclination to
be better bobsledders in some cultures
bowling is more present and other
cultures it's track and field that's
more common basketball plays a bigger
role in some cultures than in others
so someone trying to say that IQ is
genetically tied to race and that we
should be allowed to talk about it
because we do the same thing for sports
might be committing the exact same
fallacies when thinking about sports as
when they do with IQ from a social
perspective and somebody trying to make
this point might also be failing to
recognize that intellectual ability is
orders of magnitude more dynamic and
complex than athletic ability from a
biological perspective which they claim
to care about we can say with
significant certainty exactly what makes
someone a better runner versus being
better at lifting heavier weight versus
being better at throwing a ball you
can't reduce Angele intelligence to the
same kind of analysis so someone making
this argument comparing or equating
sports to intelligence is on Malta
levels equivocating are not even
understanding this debate in response to
what I've previously said about race in
IQ something else I've been seeing
people defend is this premise that
regardless of what other conclusions we
can or cannot make about IQ IQ tests are
simply really good predictors of success
in life and people often use this either
to justify the utility of IQ tests and
keeping IQ tests as part of the
conversation about race and intelligence
as well as to explain why races who
score lower on IQ tests also have lower
incomes or whatever other parameter it
is that they're focused on so let's
reset this what IQ tests are best at
indicating is whether or not someone has
a serious lack of intelligence okay
iq test measure very specific things
short-term memory some pattern
recognition some verbal abilities
processing speed to some degree visual
spatial processing a particular type of
comprehension
there is no question at all that if
someone scores an 80 on an IQ test that
they are lacking in those categories as
measured and relevant by the IQ test
but that's somebody who has some pretty
serious challenges anyone who accepts
that IQ tests are effective at screening
out people who have significant
cognitive limitations would then have to
ask the question well at minimum if you
have normal intelligence or higher what
is IQ really tell us about success and
the answer is not very much IQ scores
among people with normal intelligence
can give us a sense of who's better at
taking tests or better at accomplishing
tasks that are similar to IQ tests and
at doing jobs that require thinking in
narrow boundaries like an IQ test and
some might call them paper pushers
that's what in Assam Talib calls ìwhy
eyes or intellectuals yet idiots this is
his term not mine so when we're trying
to determine whether there actually are
correlations between IQ and success how
are we measuring success
let's for a moment say that you could
measure success by wealth or income it's
not the only way many people do really
great important things and they don't
make a lot of money but in western
capitalist society we might look at
wealth is at least one factor that we
would say success and wealth are not
interchangeable but significantly
complementary there is no statistically
significant correlation between IQ and
wealth beyond seriously cognitively
limited people you can definitely come
up with some kind of sort of circular
reasoning to say people with high IQ
have more bureaucratic success they hold
higher positions on paper at different
institutions they do well in these
hierarchically based jobs that are
similar to IQ tests which wouldn't be a
big surprise but there's no correlation
with wealth when someone with a high IQ
has a job with tasks that are like an IQ
test they're going to do well but that
doesn't correlate IQ with success as
defined by wealth just with success that
is similar to the IQ test themselves
check out this chart plotting net worth
versus IQ at the bottom you'll see that
for IQs ranging from 70 to 90 there is
definitely a clustering of low net worth
once you get past the IQ range 70 to 90
it is a very statistically noisy
distribution or instead of wealth you
can also look at IQ versus income
definitely a slight correlation but
income is not rising nearly as fast as
IQ especially once you get past that 70
to 90 IQ range where it almost levels
out totally from a scientific
perspective what we have here is a
correlation that works in the left tail
but not the right tail which suggests
that IQ is mostly useful for identifying
people who are seriously limited in
their intellectual capacity you see the
correlation with so-called success at
low IQs but the correlation goes away at
high IQs this makes it a bad predictive
measure beyond telling us who has really
serious learning disabilities which by
the way we can figure out without IQ
tests another important
doctor you know how lots of people on
the right like to say academia isn't
real life they say you know the real
world simply doesn't work like an
academic sociology department or like a
liberal arts college the same applies to
the concept of an IQ test in the real
world when you're presented with IQ type
questions it's not just about getting
the right answer within those artificial
constraints you have to figure out is
this question relevant you have to
figure out why am I being asked this
question you have to figure out is my
time better spent elsewhere than
answering this question and as Nassim
Taleb has written an IQ test asks you in
a sequence 1 2 3 4 X what is X finding X
in that limited away is very rarely
something people are asked to do in the
real world but more importantly in the
real world people would say why is it
important to find X IQ does not measure
that but real world success depends on
that type of thinking so once again to
compare IQ and success let's look at IQ
relative to specific elements of job
performance correlations go from minus 1
to 1 okay so anything from 0 and up
means that there is a correlation a
correlation of 1 would be total
correlation like for example the
correlation between being Homo sapiens
and being human is 1 training success in
the military and IQ have a slightly
larger than 0.6 correlation on the other
hand job performance in medium
complexity jobs correlates with IQ at
about 0.5 creativity correlates with IQ
below 0.4 and leader effectiveness
correlates with IQ at roughly 0.3 so you
can still look at that and say well
listen 0.6 correlations are pretty high
and you're right
but once you account for a bell curve
distribution you have to realize why
this is of very limited usefulness to us
if we look at just the correlation
between IQ and performance in general it
looks like this
this doesn't make any sense unless as I
mentioned IQ is merely a tool to
identify people who are significantly
limited in their intelligence and
cognitive abilities these correlations
are low enough that there is a massive
overlap between supposedly low IQ and
high IQ jobs check out this chart which
shows a whole bunch of different jobs
and the IQ ranges of the people who do
them a quick glance at this looks very
overwhelming Wow the IQ range of
janitors and machine operators and truck
drivers is just so much lower than the
IQ for doctors and professors and
electrical engineers but remember these
are ranges and if you look very closely
at this you'll notice that the top 25%
of janitors have a higher IQ than the
bottom 25% of college professors and of
course part of this is circular because
medical school requires that you've done
well on things like SATs which
correlates with IQ because they're
testing very similar things imagine how
many lower IQ people could be doctors if
more opportunities were given to people
without high SAT scores who might still
be a great doctor or a great professor
if the tests required to be a professor
or doctor require high IQ that's going
to restrict those fields to people with
higher IQ without ever having to
demonstrate that the high IQ is actually
necessary to be successful in those
fields so yeah the people who peddle the
race realist stuff about IQ are usually
the same people who have this mantra
about how important IQ is and how
fatalistic and linked to success it is
which makes sense because IQ tests being
relevant or useful to begin with is a
necessary premise for everything else
that follows in these hypotheses they
will say IQ tests are an authoritative
measure of intelligence and it's the
most accurate measure of intelligence
and of human potential and that's how
the race realists ensure that the next
claim really comes with a sting the
claim that black people or Hispanic
people or whoever are on average
destined to have lower IQs so basically
those groups are predetermined
to live measurably lower quality lives
and that's just that it might be sad we
might not like it but it's the truth
but IQ doesn't measure all types of
intelligence or even measure potential
for success in life it doesn't even
really measure your full potential to
perform on the IQ tests themselves
children's IQ test scores can increase
with certain type of educational
interventions and with changes in
environments people of the same genetic
IQ potential for lack of a better term
would score differently when raised in
different parental or socio-economic
situations environment is a massive
factor and one of the most interesting
counter points to the racial IQ success
theory is Polynesians native Polynesians
are a racially or ethnically homogeneous
group that spread out over a massive
massive environment ranging from within
New Zealand throughout islands in the
Pacific all the way to Easter Island
with drastically different levels of
success in economics in technology
development in food production longevity
and in many other factors what matters
were the environments they spread to
which allowed very different food
production when you have a food
production surplus that dictates when
you can actually start to have members
of your population specialize in tasks
beyond the gathering of food itself you
start to develop politics and technology
and ultimately the level of success is
measured by modern Western standards is
heavily dependent on this now there are
ways in which IQ is partly heritable
there are studies involving identical
twins who are raised in separate
environments or adopted children not
raised by their biological parents that
show this there is not a total consensus
as to to what degree IQ is heritable or
how strong the correlation is between
differences in IQ and differences in
genotypes
IQ heritability can even vary widely
based on when and where you study it
under what circumstances making it much
more difficult to nail down is it a
point to correlation is at point five is
it something else
but there's not much disagreement that
IQ can be genetically inherited to some
extent it's more than zero but it's
definitely not one but then the question
is is that the complete story or even
nearly enough of it to understand what
it tells us about the IQs of groups of
people and are there other facts that
would complicate things for people who
take twin studies and presume that it
points to inherent average IQ
differences that can be based on race
and the answer is what happens in
individuals does not even necessarily
have any bearing on what happens in
groups
imagine you have Group A and Group B
group a has higher average IQ scores
than Group B and you want to know is
that because of genetic differences
between the two groups to confirm that
that's the case you would need one
specific identifiable genes that
consistently cause people to have higher
IQs and Group A would need to on average
have more of those genes than Group B
has and number two the difference in IQ
between the two groups would need to be
greater than that which could be
explained by the environment and we know
that this isn't the case when we're
talking about races research has shown
us that the IQ differences we see
between races is no greater than the IQ
differences we observe between children
raised in different environments
we also know that IQs in the United
States and worldwide have risen more
quickly in the past hundred years then
could ever be accounted for by genetics
IQ is highly malleable depending on
environment and then last but definitely
not least as an extremely important crux
in all of this if you're dealing with
something biological like genetic IQ you
have to be weighing it against something
that is also biological it would be
totally meaningless for example for us
to do research on the correlation
between having red hair and being a
libertarian one is a biological trait
one is a socially constructed trait race
is a socially constructed trait not a
distinct biological concept
but this is the position of the NIH the
APA the American Anthropological
Association there is no gene or set of
genes that all people from one race have
there's so much genetic diversity within
what we refer to as races that any
conversation about weighing a biological
variable like genetic IQ against race is
moot from the beginning but some people
were even saying that the NIH and the
APA take this position on race because
they are institutions controlled by
liberals I do want to just break this
down again because it really is what
makes the entire race realist argument
about genetic IQ completely implode in
biology we do not have genetically
discrete groups based on continent of
origin or skin color or what we would
call black white asian Indian Hispanic
we have patterns of continuous variation
from a continental level all the way
down to the population level rather than
these abrupt clear differences between
continents this is an example we used in
the other video but I think it's a good
one
sickle cell anemia there's a
misconception that black people get this
disease because there's something
genetically that black people have in
common
here's a map of the distribution of
sickle-cell anemia which is common in
the Middle East and India as well
because it develops where malaria is
common it has nothing to do with being
black or african and black people
sharing DNA there's nothing that all
Africans or Asians or white people have
in common within their races that's not
shared between races but you might be
thinking people within races have to
share something genetically because I
can look at someone and I can tell what
race they are there are physical
features in common and these are based
on genes like for example these two
people clearly these are two people of
African descent there's something
visually distinct about people of
African descent you'd be wrong the man
on the left is an Aboriginal Australian
and the boy on the right is a Jarawa and
indigenous people of the Andaman Islands
in Southeast Asia we
nothing about their genetics by looking
at them and your average person from
either of these two regions would have
very little in common genetically with
someone from Africa dark skin dark kinky
hair is an adaptive trait that developed
some people who live near the equator on
any continent and by the same token a
person from Nigeria and a person from
Zimbabwe wouldn't be assumed to
necessarily have much in common
genetically either neither would someone
from France and someone from Russia even
though they may both look white so you
quickly realize why trying to correlate
a specific genetic trait with a
genetically arbitrary variable like race
or continent doesn't get you anywhere
you have to under the understand the
difference here between the general
notion of IQ being heritable on an
individual basis from parent to child
which is all that we actually learn from
the twin studies where we see IQ
inherited to some degree and the more
specific notion that there's evidence
for average genetic IQ differences
between races which would then also
assume that race is even a valid factor
biologically against which to measure
genetic IQ differences it's time to move
on from this it's passe I know I will
get another series of rebuttals from
people in the audience but for the time
being we've said more than enough about
race and IQ and there are really
important issues that we actually have
to solve on planet Earth for Homo
sapiens future